pequeña final le llaman a la disputa por
el tercer lugar pero nada pequeño vimos
aquí en el estadio califa en este
partido entre Croacia y Marruecos
Victoria para los croatas dos goles o
por uno para quedarse con el tercer
lugar de este mundial de Qatar 2022 los
croatas abrieron el marcador en el
minuto quinto desde una jugada de pelota
quieta que salió de modric y Mayer y que
fue finalmente Guardiola el defensa aquí
en clavó de cabeza la pelota al fondo de
la red de Bono pero los marroquíes
responderían muy rápido dos minutos
Después nada más también jugada de
pelota quieta y también una defensa esta
vez
quien metería ese segundo ese gol para
poder empatar el partido sin embargo los
croatas continuaron aferrándose a poder
marcar un segundo gol y llegaría ya en
el minuto 42 un golazo un disparo
enroscado increíble por parte de orsich
que da contra el poste y luego se mete
en el fondo de la portería de Bono fue
un partido muy bueno de muy nivel
especialmente en el primer tiempo donde
tuvimos de pronto muchas más
oportunidades de gol de ambas partes en
el segundo Croacia trató de encontrar
ese tercer gol los marroquíes también
continuaron peleando Ustedes han visto
cómo han sido los Leones del Atlas a lo
largo de todo este mundial pero
finalmente no se les dio ahora Croacia
se queda con este tercer lugar ese lugar
en el apoyo que mejor manera de despedir
a Luca modric el hombre que ha sido el
cerebro de este equipo a lo largo de los
últimos a 15 años que ha llevado a este
equipo también a la final de un mundial
como lo logró Hace cuatro años y pues
esta es la despedida de croata de la
historia de los mundiales